salue ce matin à la demande générale de
ce que vous avez sur facebook twitter et
dans les commentaires youtube je vous
fais un master class sur les derbys
régulier en anglais ça sent la rigolade
y'a pas de techniques magiques mais il
ya plein de technique pratique il ya 200
verbe à peu près régulier en anglais
c'est beaucoup de sang vert pour tout
vous dire même les anglais eux mêmes ne
connaissent pas tous le revers des
réguliers en anglais est un verbe
irrégulier c'est un infinitif un
prétériter un participe passé petit
bonus quand même il ya plein de verve
qui ont la même forme de base le même
prétérite le même participent à ces
identifier les ai commencé par apprendre
cela comme permettre qui se dit houle
est l'athlète m'emballe est la tête quoi
il faut pas se priver de ça il faut
surtout apprendre les poux simple en
premier il n'y a pas d'ordre prédéfinis
que votre horde à vous qui compte
ensuite vous pouvez continuer à
apprendre par groupes constituant vous
même les groupes qui vous intéresse vous
pouvez construire un groupe de verbe
dont le participe passé et la forme de
base sont identiques et comme ça vous
avez juste à apprendre le verbe sa
traduction et son prétérite ça vous fait
une étape en moi personnellement moi
j'avais construit des groupes de verbes
qui subissait la même transformation
federer comme préféré qu'ils finissaient
tous par la lettre t vous pouvez dans
cette piscine de verbes irréguliers
trouver votre propre logique pour faire
vos propres groupes et l'ain ont rejoint
ce que je dis à chaque fois sur une
vidéo sur la mémoire c'est vos
techniques à vous vos préférences qui
vont faire que vous allez mieux retenir
quand je dis à prendre part groupe
d'ailleurs c'est pas anodin il vaut
mieux apprendre parcours de 10 voire de
20 mai par petits groupes de dix et
régulièrement injecter un nouveau groupe
de disto que d'essayer de faire une
grosse masse d'un coup quand vos groupes
sont faits quand ils sont écrits camps
qui sont identifiés commencer par les
groupes que vous aimez le plus qui vous
semble plus simple à retenir ne vous
compliquez pas la vie mais pour bien
ancrer tout ça dans votre mémoire et le
tenir dans le long terme il va falloir
trouver d'autres techniques c'est pour
ça que je fais un master class
une technique qui fonctionne très bien
c'est la visualisation comme d'habitude
le cerveau adore se nourrir des images
quand vous apprenez un verbe visualiser
l'action qu'elle représente
ayez une image précise de l'action de ce
que ça veut dire réellement et si vous
voulez être vraiment malin vous allez
utiliser les principes de la
mnémotechnique que je vous expliquais la
semaine dernière dans une vidéo grâce à
ça vous allez tout associés ensemble
l'image de l'action le fait de l'avoir
verbalisé dans une phrase est un ancrage
mental pour faciliter la récupération
exemple pour voir si saussines je vais
simplement visualiser plein de gens
autour d'une table en train de regarder
si saucisses
une grosse assiette si saucisses quand
je vais penser à voir j'ai pensé à
toutes ces personnes en train de
regarder le plat où il ya six saucisses
et instantanément je vais me rappeler
que si sow et sin 6 on s'est compris une
fois que vous avez fait tous vos petits
groupes que vous les avez isolés que
vous avez peut-être trouver des moyens
techniques pour les apprendre vous les
imprimés vous les découper vous les
noter sur des post it ou vous voulez
mais vous en mettez partout dans votre
portefeuille dans vos toilettes
on le sait aujourd'hui c'est plus un
secret l'endroit on apprend le mieux ces
verbes irréguliers c'est aux toilettes
dans votre voiture dans votre sac
l'idée c'est d'optimiser toutes les
minutes perdues de votre vie pour
pouvoir réviser en permanence les verbes
irréguliers et les groupes que vous avez
défini c'est idéal parce que vous
n'allez pas consacré temps ça vous allez
juste récupérer du temps perdu à droite
à gauche si vous êtes conducteur dans
les bouchons vous ennuyer plus pour
réviser vos verve et régulier aux
toilettes vous apprenez votre anglais
durant les publicités à la télé vous
pouvez vous les repasser dans votre tête
et si vous avez un trou tac vous
regardez quand quelqu'un vous parlez que
vous faites semblant d'écouter me la
fait pas je sais que vous le faites des
fois vous passez vous vos derniers
groupes dans la tête en faisant ça je
peux vous assurer qu'en quelques
semaines vous connaîtrez les 50
principaux verbes irréguliers et encore
vous dit quelques semaines ça va être
plus rapide que ça avec la traduction la
forme de base le prétérit le participe
passé comme on est samedi que le samedi
c'est le master class je vous ai donné
plein de possibilités plein de
techniques différentes et j'espère que
vous allez piocher un petit peu là
dedans pour optimiser votre
apprentissage des verbes irréguliers et
bien sûr si ce genre de master class
vous plaît mettez un pouce en l'air pour
me le faire savoir
vous pouvez aussi vous abonner à la
chaîne ou me laisser un commentaire je
lis tous vos commentaires ne l'oublié
pas et en plus en général je réponds
tout à l'heure à 16 heures ce sera le
live que je ferais sur périscope le
premier live c'était pour fêter les 2500
abonnés on est déjà 11 bill c'est super
prenez votre mental au avec vous je le
fais sur périscope parce que je maîtrise
pas bien encore les live sur youtube et
je voulais pas reporter la date
je ne sais pas si je pourrai regarder la
vidéo pour la partager sur youtube et
après je découvre tout ça en même temps
que vous passez un excellent samedi quoi
qu'il arrive rendez vous demain à 11
heures pour le prochain mentale vlog
ciao